deux troupeaux de brebis soit près de
400 animaux mais aussi 70 vaches
laitières la ferme de la bergerie
nationale à rambouillet se doit donc de
poursuivre son activité malgré le
confinement depuis le 16 mars plus
d'accueil plus d'animations mais un
tiers des effectifs restent en activité
cinq salariés veille au bien être des
bêtes mais aussi à trouver de nouveaux
moyens de valoriser la production et de
poursuivre la vente ce qui a changé
c'est principalement au niveau du
secteur laitier
l'eau recueillie si nous avons un
troupeau de vaches laitières qui est
principalement destiné à la production
de yaourts et de fromage pour les
cantines scolaires
donc évidemment del annonce de la
fermeture des établissements scolaires
le carnet de commandes a été annulée en
totalité le lait est aujourd'hui
principalement transformé en fromage le
surplus de production est commercialisée
dans des enseignes locales ou par
d'autres exploitants agricoles par une
solidarité générale qui s'est mise en
place autour du monde agricole
cirque on voit vraiment un regain
d'intérêt de la part de
des commerces pour valoriser les
produits locaux et est donc en quelque
sorte en bénéficient de cet élan là au
niveau du territoire
la boutique sera aussi réouverte
dorénavant le samedi mais uniquement
grâce à un système de drive le bon de
commande est à télécharger et à renvoyer
par mail
les achats seront à récupérer de 10h à
12h ou de 14h à 17h aujourd'hui on est
en train de créer tout un tissu
commercial autour de nous peut être que
ce sera bénéfique à long terme ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup plus de notre
activité touristique
parce que là on sait que l'année 2020
sera enfin définitivement mauvaise au
niveau touristique
donc voilà les inquiétudes se portent
plus sur ce secteur un système
temporaire pour limiter au mieux
l'impact sur le site